en république nous devrons offrir à tous
la liberté d'entreprendre simplement et
c'est ce qu'offre le régime de l'auto
entrepreneur depuis six ans c'est
pourquoi je veux partager avec vous
cette conviction avec celles et ceux qui
croient à la valeur du travail et du
courage avec celles et ceux qui veulent
défendre l'esprit d'initiative avec
celles et ceux qui veulent
honnêtement gagner leur vie et qui
veulent qu'on les laisse faire avec
celles et ceux enfin qui retrouve une
place dans la société grâce à la
création d'entreprise oui le régime de
l'auto entrepreneur a été une révolution
culturelle
une révolution sociétale une libération
des énergies une expression des talents
que nous n'avions pas observée depuis 50
ans j'aimerais vous dire au nom de tous
ceux qui défendent l'esprit d'entreprise
la créativité au nom de tous les héros
qui se lancent chaque jour dans l'
aventure nous redresserons notre pays
en cherchant sans cesse à simplifier
nous redresserons la croissance en
baissant les charges en baissant l'impôt
qui pèse trop lourd sur nos entreprises
nous relèverons la france enfin en
rétablissant la confiance qui ne va pas
sans stabilité
oui notre patrie bouillonne d'énergie
d'innovation de créativité de talent pas
d'emploi ni d'entreprises 100
entrepreneurs libéraux les la france est
belle lorsqu'elle entreprendre